an Arizona Deputy lucky to be alive this
morning after falling 15 feet trying to
stop a human Smuggler near the border
the suspect 47-year-old Amber Bernadette
Wagga is charged with human smuggling
and a DUI after that high-speed chase
our next guest says this is the third
time in several days deputies have been
put In Harm's Way Cochise County Arizona
Sheriff Mark Daniel joins us now Sheriff
this must just be so frustrating to
everybody who's working in law
enforcement at the border tell us a
little bit more about this incident and
also what the impact is of these kinds
of incidents on the morale of the forces
that are down there trying to control
the flow
well good morning Rachel thanks for
having me on uh this morning you know
this is an uh a slippery slope here in
Cochise County and on our border we've
said this for last two and a half three
years it only continues to get worse
this incident here we had a deputy for
my interdiction team for smuggling he
went to deploy Tire spikes after one of
my deputies was pursuing this individual
I'm looking at here on the screen uh he
deployed the spikes actually pulling the
spikes back he lost footing on the
bridge went over the guard rail and then
down 15 feet he had multiple fractures
we had another media crew riding with us
and that's who alerted law enforcement
that he was hurt because the the
deputies continue to chase on they
didn't know their partner was hurt one
of the virtual agents was flagged down
went down into the wash area provided a
life-saving measures to include attorney
Kent my deputies up at a hospital flown
out that night once he was rescued I
hadn't got a chance to talk to him in
the last you know 36 hours to effective
his condition he had surgery the day
yesterday he's lucky to be alive let me
just say that
yeah I mean it puts our law enforcement
in danger but when you hear a human
smuggling I think so much about the
children and we've seen some pretty
harrowing images of that children being
pulled through
um you know barbed wire you know many of
them just in terrible condition what are
you seeing on that front
we see mainly the the God always these
are people that are being smuggled
camouflaged from booty to headgear and
the cartels these drivers which are
mainly U.S citizens that are coming to
my County by the thousands to drive all
about money working for the cartels
International crime but they'll do
anything they can Rachel to get out of
my county and they place my citizens at
risk they Place those who wear a badge
at risk would this ain't the first
person to be injured first Deputy has
been injured I mean we've also had to be
killed here months back by a smoker try
to run them over uh the other smoker
driver was killed in that incident this
tragedy we're seeing I had a patrol car
crash this week I had two officers and
deputies that were almost ran over by
Smugglers I mean this is ongoing every
day it's not a something we see once a
week we see it every day my citizens are
tired of it uh the state my office
sheriffs were standing United but
where's the federal government they're
absent to this they act like we don't
have a problem and why every day that
goes by we see another tragedy on the
Southwest border yeah I mean the images
that we're we're seeing here Sheriff are
they're just mind-boggling I can't
imagine how any Town any Community can
absorb this kind of influx and of course
the danger that it presents as they try
and get out of your county I just I I
don't know what to say I mean the
president refuses to go down there
um we had Elon Musk putting a little bit
of attention what's your message if you
could say one thing to the Democrats in
Congress and to the president himself
about what your community is facing
well we're facing uh you know as elected
Sheriff I take an oath of office same
one similar to what the president United
States takes and that is to protect
America I'm doing my job our state's
doing their job but where's the
president we're secretary mayorkas and
where's the majority of Congress right
now when it comes to securing this
border they're absent and this is
intended consequences let me just say
this too I said this the air date I'll
say it on your show too Rachel is you
know the president made an intentional
act to go walk the picket line once you
come walk our borderline with the agents
the law enforcement are down here doing
everything you can to protect this
country walk our line too and support us
wow Amen to that
Mark Sheriff I mean Sheriff Mark Daniels
thank you for joining us today really
appreciate your very um very insightful
and it's on the ground and it's what's
happening and our our president does
need to see it thank you for joining us
Sheriff yes thank you Rachel thank you
everybody have a good day you got it I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
aimsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis